what that means
every time you go to the gas station to
fill your tank
the federal government charges an 18
cent tax per gallon of gas that you
purchase
and a 24 cent tax per gallon of diesel
you purchase
it's a tax that's been around for 90
years
it's important because we use it for the
highway trust fund to keep our highways
going
but what i'm proposing is suspending the
federal gas tax without affecting the
highway trust fund and here's how we do
that
with the tax revenues up this year
and our deficit down over 1.6 trillion
dollars this year alone
we'll still be able to fix our highways
and bring down prices of gas
we can do both at the same time
by suspending the 18 cent gas tax
federal gas tax for the next 90 days we
can bring down the price of gas and give
families just a little bit of relief
i call on the companies to pass this
along every penny of this 18 cents
reduction to the consumers
this is there's no time now for
profiteering
there are a number of other proposals by
democrats in the house and the senate
and i hope my call for action can help
move those proposals forward as well
but we can also cut gas prices even more
in another way
that's why the second action i'm taking
is calling on states to either suspend
the state gas tax as well
or find other ways to deliver some
relief
state gas taxes average 30 cents per
gallon
already some states have acted in
connecticut and new york the governors
have temporarily suspended their gas tax
as well
in illinois and colorado governors
delayed theirs to give families a bit
more breathing room as well
in minnesota governor waltz proposes
using state budget surpluses to give
households a rebate that will help them
pay for gas at the pump or other
essential needs
i'm calling on more states and local
governments to take actions like these
thanks to our historic economic recovery
which fortified
state budgets that had been hurt in the
pandemic states are now in a strong
position to be able to afford to take
some of these actions now i fully
understand that the gas tax holiday
alone is not going to fix the problem
but it will provide families some
immediate relief just a little bit of
breathing room as we continue working to
bring down prices for the long haul
third
i'm calling on the industry to refine
more oil into gasoline
and to bring down gas prices let me
explain
i know my republican friends claim we're
not producing enough oil
and i'm limiting oil production
quite frankly that's nonsense here's the
truth
just this month
america produced 12 million barrels of
oil per day
that's the highest that's higher than
average under my predecessor
and i'm we're on track to set a new
record for production next year
plus
i've added to that supply of oil by
releasing a record one million barrels
of oil per day
from what's called the strategic for
dull petroleum reserve
in fact i just led the world to
coordinate the largest release of global
oil reserves in history including from
other countries in total that's 240
million barrels to boost global supply
and republicans falsely claim that i'm
blocking production on federal lands but
again that's nonsense the industry has
more approved permits for production on
federal lands than they can possibly use
that's a fact
my administration
also directed the sale of gasoline using
home-grown biofuels ethanol e15
this summer
which will boost gasoline supplies and
lower the price at thousands of gas
stations across america
and i welcome the recent announcement
from what's known as the opec plus
a group of nearly two dozen oil
producing nations
to increase global oil supply
the bottom line is we are setting
records in terms of american energy
production
we're supplementing that supply with the
release from our oil reserves so the
issue isn't oil production alone
the problem is
the refining of that oil in the gas at
the pump
during the pandemic
some oil and gas companies shut down
refining facilities
last week i sent a letter to the ceos of
the largest oil refining companies
asking them to work with my
administration to bring refineries back
online
to get more gas to the pump at lower
prices
the secretary of energy
jennifer granholm and members of my team
will be meeting with many of these
refining companies tomorrow
and i hope they'll come up to the table
with some real ideas
and practical steps in the near term and
i'm prepared to act quickly and
decisively on the recommendations if
they make sense to address the immediate
challenge in front of us and the
american people
finally
when the cost of oil does come down
we need the price at the gas stations
that they what they charge at the pump
to come down as well
for example
in the last two weeks the price of oil
has fallen
by more than ten dollars a barrel
normally this reduced the cost of the
pump about 25 cents a gallon
yet so far
gas stations have only reduced prices by
a few cents a gallon
some haven't reduced prices at all
i've heard plenty of explanations from
companies and economists about why it
normally takes time for these price
reductions to reach the consumer
i might note
that the price of a barrel of oil goes
up
it doesn't make it make take much time
for the price of the pump to go up
so let's be honest with one another
my message is simple
to the company's running gas stations
and setting those prices at the pump
this is a time of war
global peril ukraine
these are not normal times
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you are
paying for the product
do it now do it today
your customers
the american people they need relief now
so let me summarize
today i'm calling
for a federal gas tax holiday
state gas tax holiday for the equivalent
relief to customers
oil companies to use their profits to
increase refining capacity rather than
buy back their own stock
gas stations to pass along
the decree
not to decree but the decrease in oil
prices to lower prices at the pump
and together these actions could help
drop the price at the pump by up to one
dollar a gallon or more
it doesn't reduce all the pain
but it would be a big help
i'm doing my part
i want the congress the states and the
industry to do their part as well
and let's remember how we got here
putin invaded ukraine
putin invaded ukraine with a hundred
thousand forces
just look at the facts
since the start of the war in ukraine
this year
gas prices have risen by almost two
dollars a gallon in the united states
and sometimes more around the world
but it wasn't just putin's invasion of
ukraine it was refusal of the united
states and the rest of the free world to
let putin get away with something we
haven't seen since world war ii
i said at the time
siding with ukraine during the most
serious aggression in europe since world
war ii defending freedom defending
democracy
was not going to go without cost for the
american people and the rest of the free
world
we were going to have to pay a price as
well
in the cost of military equipment
economic assistance humanitarian relief
and
sanctioned russian banking industries
russia is also the largest or one of the
largest oil producers in the world
we cut off russian oil into the united
states
and our partners in europe did the same
knowing that we would see higher gas
prices
we could have turned a blind eye to
putin's murderous ways
the price of gas wouldn't have spiked
the way it has
i believe that would have been wrong
i believe that then i believe then and i
believe now
the free world had no choice
america could not stand by
and the west could not have stood by
although some suggested at the time and
just watched putin's tanks roll in
ukraine and seize a sovereign country
if we did stand by
putin wouldn't have stopped
putin would have kept going and we'd
face an even steeper price
and it wasn't just me
the american people understood
the american people rose to the moment
the american people did what they always
had done
defend freedom around the world
they chose to stand with the people of
ukraine
we had near unanimous support in the
congress
democrats
republicans and independents for
supporting ukraine knowing full well the
cost
so for all those republicans in congress
criticizing me today for high gas prices
in america
are you now saying we were wrong to
support ukraine
are you saying we were wrong to stand up
to putin
are you saying that we would rather have
lower gas prices in america and putin's
iron fist in europe
i don't believe that
look
i get the easy politics of the attack i
get that
but the simple truth is gas prices are
up almost two dollars a gallon because
vladimir putin's ruthless attack on
ukraine
and we wouldn't let him get away with it
we're doing everything we can to reduce
this pain at the pump now
and if those experience has shown us
anything
it's that we need to grow and harness
more energy here at home
let's lower the price of electric
vehicles
so we never have to pay at the pump in
the first place
major auto companies are preparing for a
50
of future sales to be electric vehicles
by 2030 100 by 2035
we're already building secure supply
chains to build these electric vehicles
here in america
and we're investing almost 100 billion
dollars in public transit and rail
for all the studies show that it will
take millions of cars off the road and
significantly loose pollution if there's
a serious transportation system
available
let's keep accelerating our deployment
of homegrown resources
sources of energy like solar and wind
and nuclear and hydrogen and carbon
capture stories
and keep developing a battery
technologies so we can store that power
we need when the sun doesn't shine or
the wind doesn't blow
folks
let's make sure we're never again forced
to pay the price of a menacing dictator
halfway around the world
we can deal with the medicine media
crisis of high gas prices and still sees
the clean energy future
we're americans
we can do both we're the most qualified
people in the world
let me close with this
even as we lead the world in defending
democracy and standing up to a brutal
autocrat
there are actions we can take to help
american families now
we have taken them
we are taking them the federal gas tax
holiday state gas tax holiday bringing
back refineries putting them back online
we just have to keep going
i promise you i'm doing everything
possible
everything possible to bring the price
of energy down gas prices down
i want to make sure we all work on this
together
may god bless you all and may god
protect our troops thank you very much
sneaky
i just
did that back